hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well among the schools
of philosophy that epictetus discusses
besides that of his own stoic school it
is that of the six and as opposed to the
Epicureans or the academic skeptics
where we see
Epictetus adopting a very critical
attitude towards them and levying some
very specific criticisms areas in which
he thinks have gotten things wrong penis
doesn't say that sort of thing about the
cynics if anything he seems to be saying
that got things not only basically right
but so right that it's it's going to be
difficult for more than a few people to
live out that kind of lifestyle now who
were the cynics first of all an act to
assume an audience that isn't quite you
know fully aware of hosts of cranek
philosophy and all the schools they're
often called a minor school of
philosophy and they get started with
this guy in piston ease who was a
student of Socrates and Socrates ended
up inspiring a number of different
people who started philosophical schools
which were quite often at great variance
from each other so Plato was not his
only student
the names of very important students as
well and histamines took from Socrates
the emphasis on virtue and the you know
the idea that what's most important in
life is to understand and to cultivate
moral virtue in oneself possessions
don't really matter family relations not
particularly important particularly if
they get in the way
raising children that's not really a
central concern instead it's it's it's
you know working out for oneself what
the good is and living that trying to
live a life in accordance with nature
trying to live a life of freedom a life
of simplicity that's what he took from
Socrates the other thing that the cynics
really did take from Socrates as well is
the notion that the philosopher plays a
vital social role so Socrates talked
about himself as being a gadfly stinging
the Giant you know rather sluggish horse
that was the city of Athens which gets
himself you know killed in the process
and the cynics also perform a similar
role going around and pestering people
and saying here your life is screwed up
you're not paying attention to the right
things your priorities are all wrong hey
get with it guy
so the cynic school ends up playing a
role in the development of stoicism
these two schools are not only similar
in many of the teachings that they have
but they're also connected by way of
origins
so Zeno the guy who starts the stoic
school he studies under the cynic
philosopher practice and and so you know
there's going to be a very strong
influence of cynicism maybe you might
say transplantation of some of the key
themes then rework rethought through by
Zeno in ways that to him made more sense
than what what the cynic school
themselves were doing but there is this
you know very strong stress on virtue as
the main or even sole good in
four human beings living a simple life
the cynics were all about you know
reducing things to the bare minimum
freedom you know figuring out first of
all what is freedom is it having a big
bank account or is it being able to do
and say what you would like to do what
you think is you know the best at that
time and social criticism the the cynics
went around and like I just said a
minute ago they would harangue people
you know they'd see people dressed up
going out to a banquet and they'd say
wow how much did that stuff cost you
know that money could have been used for
something quite valuable but you spent
it on threats that you're gonna throw
away tomorrow you know all sorts of
things along those lines there they were
trying to use frankness of speech to jar
people out of a sense of complacency so
what does that makita's think about this
well the key question to ask and this is
the question that he actually asks the
young man who comes to him and says I
think I'm going to become cynic sort of
like you know somebody today might come
to their parents and say you know I
think I'm gonna go join the army or I
think I'm going to join this group over
here that has these particular beliefs
or I'm just going to take a cap here and
go travel around you know backpacking or
something like that right somebody comes
to them and says I want to become a
cynic and every penis says okay well
that's a a major investment are you up
to it not everybody can live this kind
of lifestyle
and here's why and then he goes on and
explains to the guy a number of
different reasons why one needs to you
know think this decision through so one
of these and this is something that the
the cynics have in common with the
Stoics is an exclusive focus on the
ruling faculty the Faculty of choice or
more moral purpose as you know proa
racism is translated they think that the
good lies within us it's not a matter of
our body primarily although the cynics
do in fact you're tough of their body as
much as possible
it's not a matter of our clothes it's
not a matter of our social position or
rank it's not a matter of the networks
of friends that we have all those sorts
of things are extrinsic to us and
unreliable they're not really part of
our well purpose what we do have control
over is the kind of person that we make
ourselves into by the choices and the
refusals that we engage in and how we
restructure our thinking and our
desiring and our feeling and all those
sorts of things so that's something that
they do have in common with the Stoics
and to be a stoic is already in a rather
tough proposition
according to ethnic Tina's he says not
too many people who claim to be Stoics
are in actuality living out the stoic
weiss because it's a difficult life
while you're in training the cynics you
might say this is a little bit
anachronistic but you could say they
double down on it now I say it's an
antistick because the cynics precede the
steps right but the cynics by the time
they're that they're coming out seen as
a school they have developed a kind of
way of life and the way of life that
they have chosen is a life of deliberate
poverty they don't have fixed Wellings
so they don't have a house Diogenes
actually who is one of the one of the
the cynics he lived in a barrel and
Athens yeah there's all sorts of
interesting stories about when he then
you can read all about that Diogenes
lyrics it's lives of the philosophers
what they focused on when in poverty why
because if you were going to try to do
this you probably were better off not
having too many encumbrances right they
would have a one cloak and it usually
was pretty rough they would have a staff
they would have what's blocking
translated as a wallet we might call it
satchel or a knapsack that they carried
things around it and they would they
would beg for for food or for other
things if somebody invited them to
dinner they would often go they wouldn't
promise to be a nice guest in the
so not you know saying thanks to people
because they have you know this is this
particular role of social criticism the
simple life is possible the idea was
that that would free a person for the
the better of things he got a physical
endurance diogenes again model cynic
would hug statues in the middle of
winter to try to you know toughen
himself up and then he would you know
stay out in the Sun in summertime so the
cynics were were pretty legendary for
what they would put up with it wasn't
just you know physical hardships like
that
it was also enduring the sorts of abuse
that they might get from their fellow
citizens who don't like cynics or people
like them being around the cynics also
were should put it here as well they
also had a pretty good sense of humor as
a matter of fact some of the comic
genres that we we have are originally
developed by by the Civic school that's
a story for another day so why is this
going to be particularly difficult it's
already hard to work on the ruling
faculty and to it this life of poverty
and having to beg you know putting up
with with people thinking badly of you
of simplicity and the fact that you're
cutting yourself off from external
resources and this is not something that
many people are going to be able to do
is very very much sink or swim either as
a cynic you are going to be able to
divest your some of these things or
you're going to be one of the most
envious people around and you're not
going to be a very good cynic in that
case the other thing that epictetus
points out is cynics have this social
role and there's two sides to it one is
that they are in effect
you're from God and so they're there to
tell human-beings about what they they
need to know and generally don't want to
hear they're there to criticize people
about the things that they take
seriously and remind them about the
things that they don't take seriously
they're there to show that social
conventions are not really the indices
of value that we take them to be they do
so with humor they do so with scorn they
do so with with you know shouting at
people they do so sometimes even by the
soft approach right but they're they're
going to be saying things with a pareció
or frankness or freedom of speech that
is very characteristic of them so
they're out there in the world you know
taking a stand for virtue against all
these other things in a very public way
there are also a Scouts for human beings
in that they are themselves
experientially finding out whether this
way of life really does make sense or
whether it's a bunch of nonsense and
this raises some problems as epictetus
points out a cynic had really better
have his or her act together there were
female cynics by the way there was even
a husband-wife team at one point they
really better have their act together
because if there's anything that's not
morally pure about them if there's
anything that involves some hypocrisy it
is going to show up because they're
constantly in the public sphere and
they're in the public sphere without the
protection of influential friends or
money or being able to retreat into
their house or anything like that so
Epictetus says you got to really think
this through you know there's the cynic
waiting is a wonderful way it's the sort
of thing that Hercule is you know could
be identified with doing
Diogenes you know compare himself to the
great
it is the king of Persia and thought
that he came out better in the
comparison but now all of us are deities
and actually most of us are not so he
gives them some caution and many points
in in this chapter he says here we go do
you see the spirit in which you're
intending to set your hand to so great
an enterprise take a mirror look at your
shoulders find out what kind of loins
and the thighs you have it's an Olympic
contest in which you are intending to
enter your name not some cheap and
miserable contest or another in the
Olympic Games it's not possible for you
merely to be beaten and then leave but
in the first place you have to disgrace
yourself in the sight of the whole
civilized world not immediately before
the men of Athens or Sparta or Netcom
Palace and in the second place the man
who carelessly gets up and leaves must
needs be flogged before he's phlogiston
sucker thirst and scorching heat and
swallow quantities of wrestlers sand so
he's saying you know it's like entering
the Olympic Games if you actually want
to be a cynic expect that people are
going to take that very seriously and
they're going to be watching you so you
know what is his general evaluation of
this great way of life the cynics are
fundamentally right about certain things
but it may not be a practical way of
improving our lives for many people